ladies and gentlemen welcome to reddit
saturday
ah what's up how you doing that was
messy and also underwhelming somehow at
the same time i hope you're doing well
hey it's a lazy saturday guys you guys
know what that means we're doing memes
it's what we do around here guys you
know the rules you know the game top
meme
platinum not only that though not only
that wait a second
opportunity of our era also seal of
approval that's it
coffeezilla as nicki minaj no
no i don't i'm i'm deep i'm unsettled i
have deep fakes gone too far
coffee is the john wick of guru killing
ah now we're talking about
seriously we have the same like his
beard my beard
i don't know dude i don't know who he
thinks got a better beard guys brian
rose did a live stream this afternoon
had 400 viewers
a third were trolls i love how this guy
blocks anyone who dares to speak against
him
yes exactly funny how most of the people
here aren't even from london or even the
uk that's the problem he's his audience
is not
like targeted towards the to the uk i
told you guys in my last poll my last
community poll i told you guys i want to
get more votes on that one community
poll than brian gets in his entire
election campaign
when dan lok sees one of his students
made money
[Music]
you guys are getting you guys are
getting paid wait can you tell me how to
do that honestly
i'll take your course dan lok's like
wait
how'd you do that coffeezilla math
coffee plus zilla equals coffee's yes
guys does anybody know where that name
comes from i'm gonna just explain it
it's from one of my favorite movies of
all time from one of my favorite scenes
ever let's take a look at it real quick
so you know
where sifu came from listen you gotta
know your history you're gonna be part
of the community gotta know your history
boys
i'm gonna have some coffee what do you
want some uh milk or uh
what hell no milk coffee's fine
yeah i drink it i'm hip i don't know
this is espresso you know it's like
coffee
okay that's it that's that's this whole
thing dude espresso it's like
coffee's a pretty lame origin story
actually
a unofficial coffeezilla seal of
disapproval
yeah did true joe that's that's the face
i make when i find out people
have a course when i'm interviewing them
i'm out of spot of course
guys sunday i have to address this i
guess that's
better now than ever i want to be
transparent with you guys okay
i have this guy on carl dom i kind of
still like the guy i mean
we're not on bad terms or anything but i
interviewed him and this whole time he's
telling me how he spots all these other
gurus courses he's taking all their
courses
calling them out tell me i don't find
out he has a fifteen hundred dollar
course he sells
so it's like you're calling out the guys
with the fake courses but then you have
a
court i don't know i'm
i i don't like it guys i don't like that
literally it's harder to find a guy
without a course than with a course
because all i knew about was he has a
free course and so i was like oh well
that's fine
but then it's like 1500 paid cards it's
hard to avoid i apologize in advance uh
let me just set the record straight just
across the board guys
if it's over like 50 bucks i'll never
endorse it i'm not gonna
endorse that right but uh yeah i just
wanted to address that real quick
because a lot of people were upset about
that rightfully so because
i do not like 1500 courses you guys know
me that's not
an investment that i think is almost
ever worth it um
so that's just to address that real
quick i guess that
that video kind of gets that face
hey kid
let me guess you didn't donate look hey
look let me guess did you donate though
but you didn't donate
but you didn't donate
[Music]
youtube showed us down we need a freedom
platform
more like the cops shut him down
[Music]
dude did anyone see the fact that he
said he followed all the protocols and
then he shaken's hand this guy is a
pathological liar anyway i'm just gonna
get all heated so i won't say anything
sorry about that sorry about that uh it
just is what it is
the click funnels award be like guru's
showing you their click funnels award
you realizing they made all that money
from their courses
i know this is the thing that no one
understands they go wow look at what a
great businessman i am and they show a
clickfunnels award
but that's just from them selling what a
great businessman they are
it's uh it makes no sense how
coffeezilla looks when he defeats fake
gurus
we're gonna definitely get copyrighted
claimed for that uh that soundtrack
let's be honest
i'll just sing over it and then maybe we
can play the rest of it
all right yeah uh it's pretty good brian
rose talking about his credentials to
become
mayor of london i'm just a businessman
doing business
dude i have credibility dude the guy
yeah yeah yeah it's like it's the same
thing with the clickfunnels thing what's
his actual credentials he convinced a
bunch of people to take a course like
literally the mayor of london will be a
core seller if ryan rose gets elected
when the god himself is scamming fake
bot
i appreciate your review do you have do
you experience difficulty in trading
inbox adams whatsapp
dude i know i know they guys
they have figured out that my community
is a bunch of people who either love
seeing scammers get taken down
or people who are susceptible to scams
so
guys do not engage in this stuff warning
warning
nine to five is a scam albert einstein
guys there's so many
fake fake quotes
but this is not one of them albert
einstein was well known
uh to be an mlm supporter and he was
right
true next meme coffeezilla versus
pyramids game
it's time for a pyramid scheme scam
crusher
i love when low quality memes get so
many uploads dude that's like the true
spirit of memes this is this is it
when coffeezilla saw the yta method for
the first time oh here we go
i really believe that this is the
greatest opportunity of our era
this is gonna end badly for you i want
you to know that
dead i'm telling you hopefully
us the coffeezilla army and yours truly
we can put a stop to these scammers
getting away with this kind of stuff
because it's ridiculous it's gone on
this vlog
next meme amish will make all your
wishes come true
oh look at that
amish finally gets his deep fake this is
the stuff he deserves okay he's been
neglected for far too long in this
community
friday drip episodes guys don't forget
uh but look at this look at this man
teaching the padawan dude amish is like
a thousand years old so that makes sense
i'm just kidding he's gonna hate that i
said that
don't call amish old guys don't do it
yes
here in my garage got this new
lamborghini here but do you know what i
like
more than wealth butt plugs
okay uh yeah
all right then coffeezilla when a
scammer copyright strikes his video yes
yes i know this is gonna end badly for
you i want you to know that dude
oh it's true it's true guys don't do it
just you know what hey let the free
market go let people have free speech
these people are all fans of free speech
till it's about them right and ladies
and gentlemen it looks like that is the
highest upvoted meme actually because
this one was done before i started the
competition
so uh this is actually the winner so you
sir
get platinum number one okay
thanks for pumping the reddit that's my
private message to you sir
uh appreciate you and also of course we
gotta give him the golden coffeezilla
seal of approval i approve
of this message straight straight from
coffeezilla that's it
boom thank you for playing thank you one
and all but before you go before you
leave i want to say a few things number
one
this is the last saturday and really the
day before
uh the last day of the month in other
words possibly
the end of daily let me know guys in the
comments below
first of all if you enjoyed it i know i
did it it's been one of the most
rewarding times of my whole time on
youtube and i want to thank you for that
because the growth we've seen is
incredible but more importantly
i feel like it's gelled the community in
a way we've never had before and
something about that day-to-day
interaction has been really rewarding
i don't know if i physically could do it
it's like an
insane amount of work i have so much new
respect uh for these daily youtubers
even though i like in in the past i was
like oh you're just kind of getting a
video out of date dude it's
so much work so uh you know i'm gonna
look into if we can continue it if
possible
no guarantees yet um but just know
that i want that if i could i would make
you know all those videos for you and
more
um because i'm so appreciative of the
community we've built and a big thank
you to everyone who subscribed recently
who's been here since day one the day
oneers special shout out to them
you guys are what makes this community
so special right this community of
people who rally around the idea
that you don't need to pay two thousand
dollars to get a basic education
into the basics of finance into the
basics of
amazon stocks forex you don't need to do
that guys
you need to read a book you need to rely
on yourself you need to build a skill
that's what we believe
here on coffeezilla uh so i want to
thank you for making this what it is
guys and if you want to become even more
of a part of the community you can go to
our slash coffeezilla underscore gg
to join the gang because next week i
think we're going to do
probably at least one more uh reddit
saturday
i don't know if it's gonna be daily or
anything but we're gonna do another one
and for that competition
put in a mega thread we're gonna have a
mega thread of who
is the new guru you wanna see exposed
let me know their
highest upvoted guru gets a little
analysis we take a look at
okay so that's basically it i hope you
had a laugh hope you had some fun
hope you joined the community copies of
underscore gg
and i will see you maybe for the last
daily upload
[Music]
tomorrow